[Music]
when you look back on brazil's
back-to-back csgo major wins in 2016
you probably think of the fur god and
his ballsy ass lurks
look how far he's walked up behind him
he's ready he wants more kills flashbang
going through
knight oh they're stabbing each other
it's gonna be snacks going down
fur or maybe fallen and his explosive
offing
so this is actually starting to turn
once more and work out in favor
oh i was going to say mouse boards but
fallen through the wall gets one at
shadow a brilliant play
finds next as well maybe you remember
the times taco
stood up to be counted it's a one-on-one
guardian versus taco
it may just be destined to be and it's
luminosity winning their first
major championship or of course there's
coldzera
and his well you know
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's going to hit the ground
there's cold oh
how does he do this but what if i told
you that the
secret to sk luminosity's success wasn't
their sneakiest
most systematic most supportive or
famously suspended superstar that much
of them becoming the best cs go team in
the world during that time
actually had to do with their most
inconsistent
inactive and controversial player
meet lincoln fnx lao a 1.6
prodigy turned cs go veteran who after
winning his first major at
16 became one of the biggest celebrities
brazilian cs has ever seen
unfortunately he's also its most
troublesome
and has suffered countless kicks as a
result
it's nothing to do with what happened
uh in the game it's all to do with his
attitude
he's someone where the rep is doesn't
work quite as hard as other people
apparently in in line with that
difficult to deal with but perhaps the
strangest thing about fnx's turbulent
career
is the fact that it's developed into a
sort of curse for the teams he's been a
part of
you see as unreliable and unmotivated as
fnx
is if you boot him from your lineup you
can pretty much
kiss your hopes of winning csgo's
biggest title
goodbye in other words no f and x
no major
okay so aside from boasting sick tattoos
being a badass martial artist
and having his own line of street wear
fnx is essentially the single most
decorated brazilian counter-strike
player of all
time after winning the eswc major in
2006
at the tender age of 16 fnx became the
closest thing his region had to a
counter-strike celebrity
but unfortunately for fnx he took to the
life in the fast
lane a little too quickly and it wasn't
long before his career
started spinning out of control
for years fnx was seen as nothing more
than a half-assing has-been who wasted
his potential
partying instead of practicing he
developed a reputation for missing
scrims
playing like crap in tournaments and was
known for being difficult to deal with
i think that in that time he was a kid
and
don't think in the biggest way like oh i
can't wait this opportunity
but following the launch of cs go fnx
decided to turn his life around
he cleaned himself up got serious about
the game
and started carrying an up-and-coming
roster to success
true to his name which is short for
phoenix this brazilian bad boy had been
reborn
earning him another shot on luminosity
which he didn't let go to waste
efforts waiting for the perfect moment
and he's going to play this patiently
there it is there's the first frag from
fnx he'll get the second as well
and now they can go in but it's down to
scream gets the first kill
but here comes zenfone x all four
kills to reference and the defuse that's
exactly what luminosity needed
now two on three bomb ticking in front
of that bomb side fnx he posts here with
the ak in hand he's killed as a teammate
he takes the one fight goes for the [ __ ]
he's gonna spray down another one scream
still defusing he can't get it
luminosity gonna win the round the rest
of course
is history alongside fallen fur coldzera
and taco
fnx racked up back to back cs go majors
we now crown the brazilian side sk as
the kings of counter-strike the best
counter-strike team in the world the sk
era is officially here against every odd
fnx had made one of the most
inspirational comebacks
counter-strike had ever seen for the
second time in his life
he'd managed to reach the very top of
his game the problem is that once again
his attitude prevented him from staying
there and in december of 2016
he found himself being booted from the
very team he'd fought
so hard to find redemption
i think fnx unfortunately for him was
was someone who got caught up in it all
um and was less serious about practice
was probably the least motivated to
practice on his team
obviously uh saw the guy out you know
drinking a little bit more at events
than other guys
and not sk specifically uh when that
team started to fall off
um that was one of the things they
looked at because it's you know they're
trying to find ways to improve and maybe
dedication
was part of it here's the crazy part
though tragic as it was
the fnx kick wasn't actually predicted
to hurt the brazilians all that much
he might have been experienced and
naturally talented but his questionable
motivation
streakiness and his abrasive attitude
made their decision to drop him
a reasonable one but as it turned out
losing fnx would hurt sk
because he injected the team with
something that's really hard to replace
he was their x factor man fnx in the
bedroom waiting and who's going to be
checking it cypnex will but
he goes down for taking a fight and
coming out on bottom
against the free fnx with one more frank
making it a double this is how brutally
turns around
180 degrees and drops the bomb carrier
and that's luminosity
he's exciting what he should do now
they're gonna go for it here he tabs
apex away now kenny he's gonna try and
see if he can hold it down he's still on
the bomb here and fnx he's going to go
for it he gets a straight head shot
triple kill for him and yeah you're
allowed to scream like that when you win
a one versus two in a pistol round this
is such a big risk right now
and fnatic they're just not buying it
now they must have heard him and they're
going to make the rotation but
the problem is now when he plants he
can't make it out and he's stuck in here
just getting the bomb down he's going to
have to take the fight there's the one
shot for example had for
aggression you had cold consistency
fallen with the flash
and then you had fnx who could just be
there to be that star to fill those
moments when one of those players
doesn't step then fnx is there to take
over the game
he was just another arrow in fallen's
quiver and i think the team has
struggled ever since he's left
fnx was just one of those guys who
didn't even need to practice
which is a good thing because as we've
seen he pretty much never did
the flip side of course is that when he
did devote himself to cs
he could dissect a server like no other
if all looked to be lost that's when fnx
would come alive
now down to seven seconds six seconds
after next in the pit he's gonna get the
one kill in that bomb he can't be
blunted inside
fnx
oh my god what a way to win that round
now
it just so happened that the atlanta
major took place in january 2017
about a month after sk gave fnx the boot
given that they lost a longtime member
of their roster
and the fact that they were playing with
a stand-in it made sense that they
failed to three-peat
but the damage was done sk had kicked
fnx
and they'd been cursed they just didn't
know it yet
over the next six months the brazilians
racked up a streak of first place
finishes that saw them
skyrocket back to being arguably the
best counter-strike roster on the planet
well until the krakov major came along
and everything
went to [ __ ] they didn't just fail to
make the finals
they didn't even make the semis now
following this alone in a one versus
four
he's gonna get one more kill but there's
only 17 seconds
he can't get this bomb part down
astralis will have done it they're in
the semi-final 16-6
against sk gaming at the pgl major
but guess who did make that final see
here's where things start to get real
tinfoil hatty
it wasn't g2 it wasn't faze or astralis
it was a tier 2 brazilian roster known
as immortals
the very roster that fnx had joined
following his departure from sk
that's right all it took was recruiting
fnx for a group of second-rate brazilian
misfits and up-and-comers to make it all
the way to the grand finals of a major
but to be clear they couldn't win the
major
why well you see they didn't actually
have fnx you see about two months prior
immortals made the startling
announcement that they decided to bench
fnx
in the wake of well you guessed it a
slew of internal issues it's very sad
that fnx
goes through those problems i mean he's
a great guy i have been playing with him
since 2009 i have a lot of respect for
him and
i like him as a person a lot but when it
comes to
to giving a good atmosphere inside the
team i think he's struggling a little
bit
and i think that's something he can work
on i mean when he's very committed when
he wants something
he's one of the best players in the
world and that's something you can take
from him
from that point on the superstitions
surrounding fnx became
way too eerie to ignore with immortals
imploding after their unlikely run at
krakov
and sk mibr continuing to fall off of a
cliff
a community-wide meme began to take
shape
one that offered an explanation for
brazil's otherwise inexplicable downfall
no f and x no major
phoenix amigos
hell fnx thought the meme was so funny
that he even began
brandishing it on his clothes and he got
away with it
see despite his attitude issues most
brazilian cs fans adored fnx
it didn't matter how destructive he was
he was
jacked wore the freshest clothes and
hung out
with the hottest dudes everyone still
celebrates this guy even when he's just
been inactive and he's wasting
everyone's time he's collecting a salary
doing nothing
even when his teams fail he never seems
to be the guy who catches the flak
right needless to say fnx hasn't gone on
to do anything significant in cs go
since his expulsion from immortals
well except for somehow being kicked by
a team that was sponsored by his very
own clothing company
and yet sad as it is to see such obvious
talent go to waste
fnx doesn't really need to rise to the
top for like the
third time in his career as far as his
cs go career is concerned the man's a
major champion he's been at the top he's
had a fantastic career
no matter how you look at it in one of
the more competitive periods in time in
cs go as well
so yes he has had a successful career in
cs go one that he can be proud of
certainly
but that's not to say he isn't on the
grind today fnx is still
roster hopping in the brazilian scene
remains a brand ambassador for mibr
and continues to manage his own
successful streetwear brand
in many ways he's just as well off as
the squads who've been
floundering since his departure look as
eye roll inducing as the meme may be
it technically holds true across 20
years and
three different versions of
counter-strike no brazilian roster has
ever managed
to win a major without fnx he's kind of
like his region's good luck charm
but whatever his future holds and
however long it takes brazil to succeed
in his absence
one thing is for sure fnx is one of
those
rare highly accomplished screw-ups
that the community will just always
stick up for
a tragic flawed superstar that everyone
wants to
rise from the ashes again and again
because at the end of the day everybody
loves a bad boy
i count fx off for a lot of times the
past and he has came back
from a lot of times and the guy is just
insane at the game so
i'm really wishing him good luck and i
hope he gets back in the next
opportunity he does
what he does best which plays good
contrast right
save you full culture my friend full
control once again
his internal issues made it so that he
couldn't stay there
prevented him prevented him from staying
there and in december of 2015
2016. and in december of 20 [ __ ]
christ
this brazilian bad boy had been reborn
erming
irming [ __ ] me fnx became a monk
fnx became what the [ __ ] was it